to be the next conservative leader the
candidates to be prime minister as you
can see being questioned by conservative
members tonight at the hustings in
cardiff police trust he's speaking now
about social care and of course we need
to do more to make sure that frontline
workers in the nhs are empowered we're
dealing with issues like gp appointments
and ambulance services but my priority
be using that money for social care to
help people like your brother
thank you um the lady here at the front
first please and then we'll go to the
gentleman at the back
hello liz hi um
during the competition there's been so
much mudslinging
whether it's shoes earrings cartoon
knives in the back or patronizing
man's playing
it's very demeaning to manage to our
party conservatives values and ethos
what will you do to repay this damage
before the election and will you have
sufficient time to implement your plans
to convince the wider electorate in that
short period of time to avoid a stalmer
government
well i do agree with you
that there have been some
unfortunate sort of occurrences during
this leadership contest frankly it
wasn't a contest i wanted and i think
everybody was quite caught by surprise
when it happened
and some of the things like the debates
i wouldn't necessarily have so many
debates again i think it's better if
we're talking to each other within the
conservative party rather than airing
our dirty linen in public so i
completely 100 agree with you on that
what what i would do as prime minister
is first of all get on with it you know
we need to start legislating whether
it's to
make sure essential services are being
provided on our railways legislating on
the tax cuts legislating to replace eu
law with new british laws we need to get
on with that straight away and i'm
somebody who does get things done in
government and i get them done quicker
what i would also do is make sure that
if i'm selected as prime minister i
appoint people in my cabinet who are
people who can be trusted and don't
spend their time leaking and briefing i
want competent people who deliver for
the people across britain and that is
what will help us win against kierstarma